now let's look at a social media star
who's helping change the face of
trucking a truck driver shortage is
making the supply chain issues worse as
we know and is making harder for people
to get the goods and christmas presents
they want now the trucking industry has
been dominated by men for a century now
it's seeing more women get behind the
wheel errol barnett hit the road with
the woman who's making quite the
impression
she is outgoing life is what you make
out of it outspoken your spouse ever got
on your nerves so bad you wonder why
they still there and out on the roads
sharing what she knows about trucking i
provide you with different places that's
hiring job searches and ways you can
save money on fuel clarissa rankin of
charlotte north carolina is a wife and
mother of two who is sharing all aspects
of life as one of the relatively few
women truck drivers why did i become a
truck driver amassing more than 1.5
million followers on tick tock she's one
of the most popular truckers on the
platform say that again
1.5 million who want to see what you're
up to each and every day yes it is a
journey rankin says stemming from
necessity i went to school for my
bachelor's in criminal justice and i was
over 50 000 in debt and i couldn't find
a job in my career how has trucking
transformed your income my first year i
came out making 50 000 now i'm well over
150 000 and that's just one truck and
that's not counting none of my social
media which with endorsements can help
her earn up to twelve thousand
additional dollars a month so we hit the
road with rankin
and her truck sparkle i don't think
you're ready
i'm ready
to see what life feels like on 5 axles
and 18 wheels come on baby come on
okay baby you don't want to use that
light today you enjoy the view i love
the road
and it's a break away from life too
because the only thing you got to worry
about is driving the truck
you see how close he was rankin was
inspired by her husband joey who
obtained his commercial driver's license
eight years ago and quickly found work
but when she got her cdl some employers
were blunt he said i would never hire
you as my truck driver he said i will
hire you as my assistant though i had
six interviews and they all turned me
down a woman actually was the one that
gave me my first cdl job she believed in
me that belief now central to rankin's
online messaging encouraging everyone
especially women to consider this as a
career right now women only make up nine
percent of the trucking industry i want
to make it and bring it up to at least
40 percent i do recall on one of her
first videos she was counting money you
know what i mean
and i'm just like if she can do it i can
do it michelle locke obtained her
trucker's license after being inspired
by rankin locke now drives with her
husband on long-haul routes across the
country i can retire from this i can
become a millionaire if that's what i
decided i wanted to do
and my mindset was there after rankin's
delivery was unloaded she stopped to
refuel
discovering a male truck driver also
inspired by her i started in april
because of her ow
really what was that like i do this for
the people
so for him to be able to quote
everything my whole platform
and tell me who i am
it's like breathtaking
returning home at the end of the day is
rankin's top priority made possible with
joey working as her dispatcher giving
them control over their schedule
allowing the tick-tock star to spend
time with their boys we sit at the
dinner table together we are a family
and i take pride in that and that's why
i make sure i educate people on my
social media to show them like no you
still have to put family first so the
money never can make you
you make the money y'all know why i do
this one woman making major moves on the
road with her family and followers along
for the ride
cbs morning's errol barnett charlotte
north carolina
you go clarissa thank you
yes we do we do my father-in-law my
wife's dad drove trucks for decades
and i know success in that business that
industry isn't based on your gender yeah
it's based on hard work and passion and
clarissa has that yeah but did you hear
what she said that she had six people
turn her down it was a woman who gave
her finally it made me think of nina
shaw who's this badass entertainment
lawyer in los angeles she's
amazing she said you want to be a woman
in power then empower other women
that is a perfect example of that
because and you see i love effects when
she meets a fellow trucker who said i
was inspired by you
men that's what it's all about yeah
saying that not just women saying that
men
and you guys heard that too family first
that's business is great but family
first that's right you go i also love
her truck she got them those curtains
those gold curtains behind her like the
truck is all tricked out no doubt really
really cool we love you
you go